Houston what do you talk about regarding
loglines in your current book so I
always like to approach a logline of one
be able to explain the the story that
you're talking about you know your the
the plot of your story needs to be
teased in the logline but at the same
time if you can also take if you can
also set up the larger play in the log
lines which primarily is creating a
world and it be able to communicate the
story world in that log line then not
only do you tease the plot but you also
teach the world which is the bigger play
and so so the log line is just the
starting point that your project has to
exist beyond the log line so the your
log line is just one story that's going
to take place hopefully in this in this
larger world for multiple stories to
take place and cross over and connect in
all these interesting ways and so if but
if you can even approach your log line
with a with an interesting world
attached and embedded in the log line
then that's gonna give you that's gonna
intrigue people maybe even more than the
plot itself so if you remember the
trailer guy getting Don LaFontaine he
was in a world you know he would just
start his like he's the movie trailer
guy yeah that like would always do those
voiceovers right he would he saw has
coined that in a world thing sure and
what what he's doing is in a world he
sets up the context of a story world and
then he's going to tell you in the midst
of a trailer what the story is inside
that world so you know in a world where
all where one day a year all crime is
legal we have a family who is being
terrorized by somebody right so that's
like you know that's how the set up the
purge so the the story world of the
purge is a country where one night a
year all crime is legal
interesting story world interesting
concept that's that that is far bigger
than one individual story but if you can
say in a world where all crime is legal
for one night a year then move into your
individual
plot now you've intrigued me based on
the plot but you've also intrigued me
because there's a cool world so me so so
it's it's it's a it's like an
establishing shot in the movie so you
know established John in the movie is if
instead of cutting directly into here
where we're doing this interview we're
gonna first show the outside of the
entire building and then move in here so
the reason an establishing shot is as a
normal thing and filmmaking is because
the audience is more comfortable knowing
where we are then moving into something
very specific and this is just the way
we like the humans and audience with
this is the way we think and that's what
we're comfortable with because if you
just jump directly into a scene it can
be disorienting this is why you need an
establishing shot so I look at at
seating a story world inside of a
logline
like having an establishing shot for
your logline so in a world where all
crime is legal for one day out of a year
that's the establishing shot then we're
jumping into the scene which is your
individual plot which you know you have
a husband and wife who who you know seek
to survive the night from a guy who
breaks in their house right so so that
so it's it's an interesting thing of
like how do we create big concepts from
the from the beginning how do we create
the big-ip
but then ultimately we get down to a
point where we need to be able to
execute and communicate it on a very
small level so how do we create Star
Wars how do we create something massive
how do we create something that can
sustain for 20 30 40 years but then when
I'm talking to you as a producer or
after I'm at a pitch fest or I'm talking
whoever I'm talking to how I boil it
down to a line what because again we
need a good story world and we need a
good story how do I do both in a log
line
typically a log line focuses on the
story but at the same time I need the
cool story world but I don't want to
just pitch the story world without the
story because then then then my products
not going to work so I need both and so
I think you craft the log line in a
really interesting way to do both it's
just a different type of a process but
to approach it but I think it's always
very helpful
you